والى انجاز تطبيق توج بفرحه عائلات طفله
اماراتيه مريضه تعد الاصغر في الشرق
الاوسط تخضع لعمليه زراعه قلب فبخطوات
دقيقه ومحسوبه انتقل الى الامارات فريق
طبي من مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي ومركز
الابحاث بالرياض يقوم بعمليه ازاله قلب من
متوفي في دبي والعوده الى الرياض لزراعته
في جسم الطفله وذلك في اقل من 24 ساعه
كانت الطفله اعتمدت لاشهر على مضخه صناعيه
لعدم توفر المتمرين
على كل من الرياض نفهم القصه اكثر ينضم
الينا من مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي مراسل
صباح العربيه محمد خالد وظلم كذلك الينا
من مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي بعد قليل من
الرياض رئيس قسم القلب في مستشفى الملك
فيصل التخصصي الدكتور محمد الهيدان اهلا
بكما ابدا معك محمد تفاصيل او في يعني
فريق مستشفى الملك فيصل تخصصي نجاحه في
الزراعه قلبين لطفلتين اصغرهما اقل من
ثمانيه اشهر حدثنا اكثر عن تفاصيل
العمليتين
اهلا سهام صباح الخير عليك وصباح الخير
على مشاهدين قناه العربيه نعم اليوم انا
احدثكم من مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي
بالرياض ااه ومن امام التحديد من امام
غرفه العمليات التي يقف من امامها الان
التي نجح فيها الفريق الطبي لجراحه قلب
الاطفال هنا في مستشفى التخصصي من زراعه
كالباين لطفلتين احداهما لم يتجاوز ثمانيه
اشهر وذلك همم بعد ان كانت تستخدم المضخه
الاصطناعيه لعدم وجود متبرع جاء ذلك خلال
فتره همم زمنيه قياسيه في اقل من 24 ساعه
انتقل بعد ذلك الفريق الطبي من الرياض الى
مكه المكرمه ثم الى دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده دبي لاجراء عمليه ازاله قلبين ل
همم متبرعين متوفيين بعد ذلك عدو الى
الرياض في هذا المكان تمت همم العمليه
اجراء عمليه زراعه القلب بطفلتين همم
ذات العمر
عشان شهر والطفله الاماراتيه شامسه التي
تبلغ من العمر ثمانيه اشهر سهام تعد
الطفله سهام همم اصغر حاله او يعني اول
حاله تخضع لعمليه زراعه القلب على مستوى
الشرق الاوسط كانت هناك حاله كامله عفوا
شامسه كانت همم اول عمليه تقضي عليه زراعه
القلب هنا في همم مستشفى الملك فيصل تخصص
على مستوى الشرق الاوسط كانت هناك حاله
سهام همم قبل عام تقريبا ولكن تعد حاله
شامسه يعني همم على مستوى الشرق الاوسط
الحاله همم طفلتين تشهد حاله همم يعني
تحسن مستمر على مستوى الصح الصحي بكل
تاكيد اخذه علي همم
المتابعه الطبيه من قبل فريق الطبيرون
مستشفى همم بعد يعني ايام قليله همم اخيرا
سهام الدعم لهجسي همم سهله الفريق من
التنقل من دوله الى اخرى مما جعل يلعب دور
مهم في اسهال او تسهيل همم دور همم
دبي لزراعه قلب شامه وطريق طبي اخر من
المستشفى انتقل الى مكه لزراعه قلب لي صح
نعم نعم في اقل من 24 ساعه
طيب محمد بالنسبه للحاله
الصحيهما قريبا
الحلقه الطبيه للطفلتين في تحسن مستمر بعد
ما يعني كانت كانوا قبل العمليه سهام يعني
يعانون وذلك بسبب اضطرابات في المساله
العضله القلب الان بعد زراعه القلب لهما
يشهدان حاله من يعني
تحسن المستمر وهم تحت يعني الملاحظه من
قبل الفريق الطبيب طيب شكرا جزيلا لك محمد
قبل التوجه للدكتور يفهم اكثر تفاصيل هذه
العمليتين توجه الى ميسي مزيد من التفاصيل
في جميع انحاء العالم يبلغ معدل البقاء
على قيد الحياه بعد عام واحد من زراعه
القلب نحو 90 بالمئه وحوالي 80% بعد خمس
سنوات واليكم بعض المحطات المهمه حول
زراعه القلب اول عمليه زرع قلب بشري
الانسان اجريت في مستشفى في جنوب افريقيا
وذلك عام
1967 لكنه توفي بعد 18 عاما بسبب التهاب
الرئوي وليس لعطلان في القلب المزروع عام
1984 كانت الطفل الامريكيه ستيفاني فاي
اول رضيع يختار جراحته زراعه قلب غير بشري
حيث تلقى صدرها قلب قرد وعاشت لعشرين يوما
بعد ذلك
سينزل من بريطانيا احتفلت باربعين عاما من
الحياه بعد زراعه القلب في اواخر العام
الماضي المثير انها اجرد زراعه قلب اخرى
عام 2005 عندما اصاب الضعف قلبها الاول
في اول العام الماضي تمكن جراح امريكيون
من زراعه قلب خنزير معدل براثيا في صدر
مريض البشري في اول عمليه من نوعها لكن
المريض توفي بعد شهرين من العمليه من
الرياض ينضم الينا رئيس قسم القلب في
مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي الدكتور محمد
الهبداني متابعه الموضوع اهلا بك دكتور
نبارك لكم هذا الانجاز الطبي الاول في
الشرق الاوسط زراعه قلب لطفله صغيره لم
يتعدى عمرها ثمانيه اشهر اهلا بكم حديثنا
اكثر عن تفاصيل عمليه يا دكتور ومبارك مره
جديده
اهلا بكم وحياكم الله وشكرا على هذه على
هذه الاستضافه صباح الخير على الجميع في
الحقيقه كان لدينا الطفله من الامارات
العربيه المتحده وكانت تعاني من فشلا في
القلب فتم قبولها في مستشفى الملك فيصل
التخصصي بالرياض وتم نقلها بالاخلاء الطبي
لكي تحظى بالمتابعه الطبيه ومحاوله تقديم
العلاج اللازم لها لما تعاني منهم المشكله
في القلب
فمرحله الانتقاليه تم وضعها في البدايه
على مضخه القلب الصناعي لمده تقارب
للشهرين حتى يتوفر المتبرع للقلب من اماره
دبي فتم انتقال الفريق الطبي متكامل عن
طريق الاخلاق الطبي الى الامارات وتم
الاتصال العضو من المتبرع به وتم نقله
مباشره مره اخرى الى الرياض وتم زراعته في
الطفله اا بعد ذلك كانت العمليه ولله
الحمد لله
في همم من نجاح الى نجاح واستقرت حاله
الطفل بشكل كبير جدا وبعد مضي شهر ونص
تقريبا من اجراء العمليه تم خروجها الى
البيت بصحه جيده معدويها ومع اهلها وهي
الان في المنزل ولله الحمد من قرابه
اسبوعين ووضعها جدا مستقر وتحت متابع
اسبوعيه من الفريق الطبي
المعالجه تمت في وقت قياسي في اقل من 24
ساعه انتقل الفريق الطبي الى دبي الى دبي
حمل القلب الى الشمس في الرياض وتم زراعته
هناك ما هي ابرز التحديات التي واجهتكم
دكتور في هذه الزراعه
طبعا هناك تحديات كبيره فاولا من ناحيه ان
العضو المزروع تم نقله من دوله اخرى فهذا
يعني لابد من وجود
التنظيمات لوجستيه كبيره
فتم التنسيق ااا في البدايه بين مركز
زراعه الاعضاء في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومركز زراعه الاعضاء في الامارات
العربيه المتحده همم حينما تم ايجاد هذا
العضو من المتبرع به فتم انتقال الفريق
الطبي عن طريق طائرات الاخلاق الطبيه
التابعه لوزاره الدفاع السعوديه انتقلت
الى اماره دبي او تم معاينه همم القلب من
المتبرع به وتم الاتفاق على انه مناسب
بالنقل فثم ما تم- اتصاله والعوده به
مباشره بحيث ان الساعات الساعات قليله جدا
التي لابد ان يتم فيها زراعه القلب
فهذه التحديات من عمليه التنسيق الدولي
ومع طائرات الاخلاق طبي تحضير الكوادر
الطبيه المؤهله لاعداد الغرف العمليات همم
لكي يتم زراعه العضو بشكل سريع لابد من
تجهيزها وعمليه التنسيق الكبيره فهذه
تعتبر تحديات كبيره لا تتم لو لا توفر
البنيه التحتيه والكوادر الطبيه المؤهله
والخدمات
اللوجستيه من الطيران والتعاون الدولي بين
السعوديه والامارات الشقيقين
يعني كانت تعاني من فشل في عضله القلب
وكانت تعتمد لاشهر على مدخل صناعيه هل
اليوم في زراعه القلب الجديد يمكن القول
انه يسري بشكل طبيعي في جسدها
نعم صحيح الحمد لله تمت متابعتي من بعد
العمليه حتى يتم التاكد من القلب يعمل
بشكل طبيعي وبدون اي مشاكل او ملاحظات
طبيه استقرارها واستقرار استخدام الادويه
طبيه لها لضمان عمل القلب بشكل المطلوب
وتم الوصول الى هذه المرحله والحمد لله
حيث وصلت الى مرحله مستقره جدا بانها عادت
الى منزلها لتعيش حياتها الطبيعيه مع
والديها ومع ذويها طيب اضافه الى هشام سكن
هناك لين تم جلب القلب من مكه الى الرياض
لزراعتها لزراعه في قلبها وهي لم يتعدى
عمرها 19 شهر حديثنا عن هذه العمليه ايضا
يا دكتور
من سبب توفر اللايك البنيه التحتيه القويه
لعمليات تنسيق زراعه القلب في اكثر من
متبرع توفر ايضا العضو اخر من متبرع به في
مكه المكرمه حيث تم انتقال الفرقه الطبيه
من الرياض الى جده بالاخلاق طبي ومن ثم
الى مكه المكرمه استئصال العضو والعوده به
الى جده ثم الى الرياض وهذه الفتره تمت
عمليه زراعه في اقل من 24 ساعه فهذا
الدليل على ضروره التوفر الكوادر الطبيه
الكبيره والمؤهله بحيث يتم اجراء
العمليتين خلال فتره قصيره في اقل من 24
ساعه وهذا طبعا بسبب المؤهلات الموجوده
وتوفر التخصصات العديده وبعدادات كافيه
لاجراء عمليات متعدده خلال فتره قصيره جدا
الطبيه في الشرق الاوسط من الرياض رئيس
قسم القلب في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصص
الدكتور محمد الهبدا شكرا دكتور على
تواجدك معنا صباح العربيه